[Música]
con nuestro primer invitado del día
hablaremos de la situación actual de la
red social Twitter bajo la batuta de
elon musk los aspectos masivos y la
situación de las personas que
actualmente Siguen trabajando en la
compañía para ellos saludamos a Emmanuel
corné el ese programador caricaturista y
escritor francés radicado en San
Francisco trabajo como ingeniero para
Twitter hasta que fue despedido luego de
keylon mouse se apoderara de esta red
social su despido según él Se debe a que
desarrolló una herramienta que permitía
a los trabajadores guardar documentos
importantes en previsión de estos
despidos masivos los saludo Emmanuel
Gracias por estar con nosotros esta
mañana de martes en directo América de
Francia 24 escribenos Entonces cómo fue
esta situación en las empresas después
de que hay lo más que tomara las riendas
les tomó mucho tiempo muchos meses hacer
esta cacería la salsa
la gente ya estaba cansada de todos los
cambios que se estaban dando pero
Finalmente nos dimos cuenta de que sabía
concretado
se te han sido
la realización que la mayoría de
personas espero a ver qué pasaba
Esto fue el desarrollo de una larga saga
de varios meses desde
ahora como y cuando digamos informando
su despido Cómo se enteraron ustedes y
sus colegas que ya no trabajaban en
Twitter
[Música]
realmente nadie me avisó la forma como
me di cuenta fue igual a la de los demás
de repente mi computador de trabajo Se
bloqueó entonces
antes de que supiera sobre mi despido y
como fui uno de los primeros me
sorprendí
eso
pero luego siguieron mis colegas
rápidamente
entre comillas yo tuve un trato
preferenciado
la gran ola de despidos tuvo lugar días
después del mío
después de cierto número de personas
despedidas la gente que quedaba prefería
hacer despedida también e irse con sus
compañeros de la empresa
fue un ambiente raro la verdad
claro también en Manuel usted desarrolló
una herramienta que permitía a los
empleados o permitir sus documentos
privados cree que fue este el motivo
principal por la que la empresa haya
decidido prescindir de sus servicios
cuando comencé a escuchar el rumor de
los despidos hice una herramienta que
permitía Descargar guardar más
fácilmente mensajes de mail
no de de mesas
Así que era como una extensión de
navegadores la herramienta no hacía nada
mágico solo automatizaba un poco mejor
el proceso porque hay muchas cosas en
las cuentas de mail profesionales que
podríamos necesitar en un futuro
profesional
por ejemplo buenas evaluaciones
colaboraciones etcétera entonces
publiqué eso en el almacenamiento de
Google porque era una extensión de
Chrome
entonces
tuvo ningún problema creo que es
información aún sigue almacenamiento
pero fue al agregar un papel
y una hora después Me despidieron
entonces esa fue claramente la razón
principal la razón directa pero como
nunca me dieron la verdadera razón de mi
despido estoy solo deduciendo
porque solo pasó una hora entre ellas
Me parece muy incierto
también Emanuel los empleados han
presentado un proceso legal contra la
compañía le preguntó cuáles son los
motivos de esta queja y que esperan
alcanzar con esta queja no presentada
ante la justicia
hay dos procesos en curso uno que es
Class action con otros colegas vamos
amor De hecho no fui yo quien empezó el
proceso fue una compañera fue la hija
amo yo ya he estado dispuesto a irme sin
más de Twitter
Pero cuando vi que mis colegas empezaron
el proceso y me preguntaron si quería
involucrarme yo respondí con gusto
el problema Este primer proceso se da
porque Twitter en este caso despidos
masivos no respetó el plazo establecido
en California para avisar a los
empleados sobre su despido antes de
efectuarlo
es sexy no soy abogado Así que no
conozco los detalles pero al parecer
Twitter infringió las leyes laborales
incluso de Estados Unidos donde los
contratos son más fáciles de incumplir
que en Francia o en Europa pero de todas
maneras hay reglas para cumplir uno más
difícil será qué hacer
y viajando
y el segundo más que un proceso es una
queja ante un organismo de protección
laboral en Estados Unidos
que estipuló que lo que yo hice fue una
acción de protección para ayudar a mis
colegas
una acción concertada por la que no
tenían derecho de despedirlo
claro Emmanuel hablemos ahora un poco de
su trabajo como caricaturista tengo
entendido que también se dedicaba
dedicar un poco la red social con sus
dibujos No
mostraban
mi verdadero trabajo en Twitter era como
ingeniero era lo que hacía como
trabajador de plata
[Música]
pero en Mis tiempos libres hago
caricaturas
el fin es un poco jugar el rol de
caricaturista político como cuando ves
en los periódicos caricaturas que
critican al gobierno y lo que pasa en un
país
La idea es considerar a estas empresas
como Twitter o Google como mini países y
cumplir el rol de caricaturista de la
prensa creo que es importante hacerlo
sobre todo con empresas de estas
dimensiones e
importancias
de llegar al público debe haber
dirigentes que acepten ser criticados y
parodiados
es importante para los empleados
burlarse a veces de ellos mismos nunca
a veces me parece que es un ejercicio
que falta en esas grandes empresas donde
no hay nadie que ejerza el rol de bufón
del Rey o de caricaturista